there's a very simple biscuit and
heads-up bisque is what you call it
cookie here very simple biscuit these
are freddo milk chocolates Wow look at
the Frog I know it was you Fredo
he broke my hot bread Odin is not
wearing pants yeah he's a Donald Duck in
it right now mine is just grabbing his
tummy and giggly excited to eat some
chocolate poor pash I'm playing a guitar
[ __ ] it's a chocolate frog but it's
not the chocolate frog from Harry Potter
do you have sensitive teeth like me this
may not be the talking for you why
getting into the premises so we got a
violet crumble here violet crumble
sounds like the name of a love poem from
the late 1700s Frog chocolate is still
my teeth how the violets crumble when
love shines not upon though the way it
shatters that matters which makes me
more like here's mate
Oh hmm oh I like this texture is nice
like dehydrated ice cream it's like a
toasted marshmallow flavor hmm sounds
like a British nannies named Carrie
right let me get your porn star name
ripe juicy cherries and coconut in the
old gold rich dark chocolate is old gold
like a brand of chocolate oh not not a
pleasant interior I must say a little
bit like rice looks like a cough drop
forever these are the chocolate and mom
likes this is some grandma's chocolate I
don't know you this don't my mom for
that old it smells like Valentine's Day
it looks like the feeling of an Almond
Joy I'm getting Thanksgiving vibes from
this you know yeah cranberry sauce that
was the best one for so far you think so
yeah it's a very mature candy bar for
mature people from mature palates
I don't want maturity when I'm eating
candy I want frivolity Chiquito Chiquito
chewy caramel fudge crunchy balls and
loads of chocolate nothing I like better
than balls with loads let me tell you
that inside it's a tunnel guess I wasted
too much chocolate
yeah they made a candy bar and they're
like wrapping another candy bar that's
everyone just like cereal picnic it's
got a lot of nuts this is the choke ito
on steroids oh that's got a crunch to it
the clips of estrodial chocolate and
wafers very uh whoa your face it's like
those wafer candies stuck into the
middle of a Snickers bar and that's some
[ __ ] Tim Tams in Tam wha-bam
mmm chocolate biscuit these are the ones
that have class and style these are the
chew that was a very refined but yeah
the Tim Tam and I think are the best of
the bunch
I like the Frog because it's just a
simple bite of chocolate in a really
gnarly shape you you like the cherry
right you know sure I've thus one way
Tim jam the ones that were kind of like
cherry there was supposed to 100 of this
chicken this is intense
by the way call this video how to get
ants
[Music]
you